barack obama speaking of people who are
totally empty inside here's what he
tweeted
and this i honest to god i saw this and
i just stared at it for a minute because
i thought this has got to be
this is so on the nose there's just
did he really tweet this this has got to
be some kind of photoshop some kind of
joke but it's not so barack obama
tweeted as we grieve the children of
yuvaldi today we should take time to
recognize that two years have passed
since the murder of george floyd
under the knee of a police officer
his killing stays with us all to this
day especially those who loved him
uh anyway he continues in the aftermath
of his murder a new generation of
activists rose up to challenge their
anguish into organized action launching
a movement to raise awareness and blah
blah blah okay i don't give a damn
uh he's tying it into george floyd
because barack obama was upset i guess
yesterday was what the second
anniversary of george floyd's death and
people weren't talking about that so we
wanted you wanted to find a way to loop
it all back around
hey i know you guys are mourning today
over
uh the fact that 20 children were killed
but remember george floyd that's what we
really should be talking about
okay george floyd
was a violent criminal lowlife
hopped up on fentanyl
who died while resisting arrest because
he was trying to pass counterfeit bills
and you're drawing any you're putting
him in the same sentence
as innocent children who are slaughtered
in mass at school
like these are comparable
in any way whatsoever
and after he tweeted this of course the
left is defending him and
uh i i started seeing these other
articles have been written recently
there was one i think it was in the
atlantic i don't remember uh saying that
lamenting the fact that uh well george
floyd's memory is is fading we're all
forgetting about george floyd already
well first of all i wish but second why
shouldn't it fade
why should why should we remember his
death exactly no one's ever really
explained that
like lots of people die in this country
every single day
and there are certain people who
are worthy of being remembered and
mourned by the entire nation
and many of them are are not though but
there are certain people who are worthy
of that
all the children who were killed in the
mass shooting
yes remember and mourn them the entire
nation the entire world that's that's
that is a tragedy worthy
of uh of
and and
which calls to be remembered and mourned
but george floyd just some criminal
scumbag
who
forced his way into a woman's home and
robbed her at gunpoint
and despite what we're told no he never
cleaned his life up but he cleaned his
life up but he died hopped up on
fentanyl trying to pass counterfeit
bills like that's how he cleaned his
life no it's just a she's a criminal
a man who was a was a predator
preyed on his own community
never contributed to anything worthwhile
is community only contributed fear and
crime and violence to it
we're forgetting george floyd so
that would actually be sign of progress
it is a sick society that remembers that
specially remembers and mourns somebody
like george
floyd and it's an even sicker society
that puts him on the same
level
and puts his death at the same level of
tragedy
as
20 kids who are killed
but this is all kind of
it's like it's like wishful thinking
because in in actuality
uh george floyd is not being forgotten
and he's the one he still has his
monuments and uh and his streets named
after him and he's gonna have schools
named after him soon enough and he's got
the murals
no it's these kids who were killed um
they're the ones
[Music]
outrageously tragically like
who end up getting forgotten almost
immediately
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends